while the jobs report provided another
sign of the the administration's push to
revitalize the economy
president biden's coming up short of his
goal to have
70 percent of american adults vaccinated
by the fourth of july
so far 67 percent of adults have
received at least one dose of a copic 19
vaccine
58 percent are fully vaccinated still
less than half of all americans are
fully vaccinated
christina ruffini is at the white house
with the very latest christina good
morning
good morning michelle look the good news
is more people are getting the shot
those numbers are up 40 percent over
last week on average
but the numbers still are not where
healthcare experts want them to be
and there's a concern ahead of this
weekend of big crowds and close contact
that those pockets of unvaccinated
americans could put summer barbecues
at risk fourth of july
to this year is different than the
fourth of july last year
and it's going to be better next year
here we go
america did not reach president biden's
goal of 70
of adults vaccinated by independence day
but the white house says there's still
reason to celebrate
deaths and hospitalizations have fallen
90
since january 20th and we want to
recognize that
progress in that work on july 4th 67
of adults have gotten at least one covet
19 vaccination
but the numbers vary by state and
southern states in particular
are lagging behind even as the more
contagious delta variant is now present
across the country i am concerned
that people who have not gotten
vaccinated
have the capacity to catch
the variant and spread the variant to
other people who have not been
vaccinated
as counties and cities prepare for large
holiday crowds
it's going to be busy it'll be crazy and
i'm going to stay away
and fireworks celebrations some folks
wearing masks if they want to some folks
don't have to
you know it's going to be responsible hi
is michigan's governor whitmer
a bipartisan group of governors has
launched a public service announcement
to encourage reluctant residents to roll
up their sleeves
although cases hospitalizations and
deaths are down
our rates are not where they ought to be
and while the numbers are still below
where they were in january
the cdc says the u.s coveted cases
spiked
up 10 percent last week those of you
haven't been vaccinated don't think
about yourself think about
your family think about those around you
that's what we should be thinking about
today
president biden will leave the white
house shortly to travel to michigan
where he'll continue his vaccination
push and then on sunday
the white house is hosting about a
thousand families of military members
and first responders on the south lawn
for celebrations and that's the largest
gathering they've had at the white house
since president biden took office thanks
christine it's just nice to see these
gatherings
again thanks for the report